إجمالي عدد الوفيات في أمريكا 410000
بحلول السنوات الجديدة هو أحدث إسقاط من
مجموعة كانت تنبؤاتها
حتى الآن دقيقة إن لم تكن أكثر
تحفظًا من الأرقام الفعلية
ويظهر النموذج الجديد العديد من الوفيات
إذا تخلينا عن بروتوكولات السلامة
وأقل بكثير إذا ارتدى الجميع  إخفاء
تدخلهم في مجال الصحة العامة ،
نعلم أنهم يعملون مع
مصادر الاستماع الخاصة بالانتخابات ، ويقولون لـ CNN إن
البيئة مثل قدر الضغط داخل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
، الوكالة التي ستوافق في النهاية
على لقاح بينما نعلن عن إنجاز تاريخي
منذ الربيع الماضي ، ضغط الرئيس ترامب
على المسؤولين للإسراع في ذلك.  رفع
الجدول الزمني لتطوير لقاح أو
دواء علاجي لعلاج فيروس كورونا
وفقًا لمصادر داخل
الإدارة التي أخبرت CNN أن الجهود
تتكثف سأستقيل على الفور
إذا كان هناك تدخل لا داعي له في هذه
العملية ،
يقول منتصف سلاوي ، الرئيس
العلمي للعملية.  جهد
لإحضار لقاح للجمهور الأمريكي
في حانة  في مقابلة أخيرة مع
المجلة الأكاديمية
العلمية ، قال إنه لم يكن هناك على
الإطلاق أي
أسئلة
تدخل أثيرت بعد أن أصدرت توجيهات CDC الأخيرة
تعليمات للدول
بالاستعداد لتوزيع ملايين الجرعات
من اللقاح في وقت مبكر في أواخر
أكتوبر ، كجدول زمني لبعض كبار الجمهور
وصف مسؤولو الصحة بأنه
غير مرجح للغاية من حيث الجداول الزمنية الواقعية ،
فنحن
لا نتوقع حقًا رؤية تطعيم واسع النطاق
حتى منتصف العام المقبل
، يظهر لقاح روسي
نتائج واعدة محدودة وفقًا
لمجلة لانسيت الطبية الشهيرة ، لكنه
لم يمر على نطاق واسع  - على نطاق واسع التجارب البشرية في
حين أن ثلاثة من مطوري اللقاحات الأمريكيين
هم الآن في المرحلة الثالثة
والأخيرة من التجربة مع
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ليوم العمل علينا التحقق من الواقع
، حيث تستمر الولايات المتحدة في متوسط ما يقرب من 40 أل
حالة جديدة مرغوبة 19 حالة يو
يًا وشهدت أكثر من ألف حالة وفاة  في
كل يوم من
الأيام الثلاثة الماضية في الشمال الشرقي ، هناك
حفل زفاف واحد في مين الشهر الماضي
مرتبط الآن بـ  ما لا يقل عن 144 حالة وحالتا
وفاة
ونقطة ساخنة تضيء في جميع أنحاء
الغرب الأوسط حيث أن بعض الزيادات المفاجئة
في حرم الجامعات لدى كلياتنا وجامعاتنا
خطط
جاهزة وتتخذ جميع الخطوات اللازمة
للحفاظ على طلابها
ومجتمعاتهم آمنة قدر الإمكان